James Franco awhile ago
he does these stunts he's a Renaissance
man yes he did he likes to try different
things and he did live readings of your
first book your book hmm
and no one knows exactly why and he did
them including him including him he did
them in front of monuments is that right
apparently now I've tried to pin him
down on this when we were doing the
interview I kind of asked him what
exactly was this thing you did and he
was very cagey but as far as I can tell
it was a live reading of my first book
in front of national monuments right
film to put on a bank of television sets
in London and then immediately shut down
by the police as far as I can tell okay
so you don't know why he could have
chosen any book but he chose your first
book to read he was when the book came
out he was one of the first people to
call me and say he was a fan and loved
it and he kept saying I think there's
something here like a thing okay because
I know I think no really Rob I this book
I think there's something here so
clearly he had something in his mind
okay so he did this you were okay with
it I mean I would be for me I'd be a
little paranoid like his email making
fun of me yeah exactly
well I couldn't I couldn't really tell I
didn't get to see the the thing in
London right and I shot down it was shut
down if you're interested I have a book
this is real of James Franco's poetry I
don't know if you'd be interested I lost
sight about his poems right now in that
way I return the favor all right
actually here's a performance art this
is a book this is real this is real this
is a real poem by James Franco and it's
called kindergarten Oh
let's get real what this is one of his
poems and I thought this can now live on
the Internet and the scales are balanced
here we go
kindergarten there am kindergarten by
James Franco kindergarten is a white
room with colorful letters high up on
the wall each letter is an animal oohs
for ostrich T is for tiger in the middle
of the floor is a great green carpet we
all sit around and sing
my friend is Adam my first friend and
Jewish his thing I loved it you know why
I love James Franco what he's the only
person to be worse than me on the Oscars
[Laughter]
[Applause]
this is what we live for when you can
make somebody like Conan legitimate it's
the log since he did that yeah people
never forget I I know we're leading
we're going into Oscar season so I know
that I'm just gonna be excuse me [ __ ]
hammered again no white you could forget
look it up
you were giving it your all that's right
kid
you